[Music]
what we wear says a lot about who we are
yet fashion is also a 2.5 trillion
dollar industry that touches everyone on
earth
i'm imran ahmed i first started trying
to make sense of the fashion business 15
years ago as it was being transformed by
technology globalization and shifting
consumer values
and so stuff like this would just end up
in a landfill yeah
now i'm on a journey to see how fashion
is recalibrating after the pandemic to
balance profit with purpose
this is the business of fashion show
join me to discover how fashion shapes
business
culture and identity and to meet the
people forging fashion's future
well i'm back here in paris for the
first time in 16 months and it's the
first time the global fashion community
is really getting together
since
march 2020
it's oat couture week the most exclusive
most elaborate and most creative event
on the fashion calendar
this is a world of rules and traditions
of exquisite workmanship and high net
worth clients able to pay six figures
for a gown do you buy couture absolutely
yeah yet the trailblazing designers
we're about to meet may not be what you
expect
among them a true disrupter in fashion
the man who made a billion dollar
industry out of ugly sneakers is staging
balenciaga's first couture show in over
50 years
we had an exclusive preview couture for
me has something very modern in its
concept because we only produce what
somebody orders this is like the most
sustainable way of consuming and the
rising star of paris whose highly
creative collections place the planet
before profit embedding sustainability
into her design process we really have
to think about the planet that we are
destroying every day so i was hoping
that maybe you know some other people of
the fashion industry were thinking about
that
but to really understand what's
happening in paris this week it's
important to take stock of the last 18
months
2020 was the worst year in the history
of modern luxury
before that annual revenues for the
luxury fashion market topped 380 billion
dollars
more than two-thirds of growth was
buoyed by the chinese at home but
especially as tourists abroad
the lion's share of revenues came from
accessories especially handbags with
designer sneakers catching up
then wuhan china locked down
kovitt hit europe during the 2020 spring
fashion show season
giorgio armani live streamed his show
from an empty theater in milan
but other brands forged on which shows
packed full of fashion insiders
in a global business so interconnected
unforeseen consequences of the pandemic
came to light
delayed weddings led to cancelled
embroidery orders out of paris
threatening the livelihoods of the
karigar artisans of india
luxury revenues plunged by more than 20
percent
companies cut costs but by the end of
2020 covid19 had still devastated
industry profitability
fashion was forced to adapt using
technology to drive creative and
business innovation
the fashion business was reimagined
through distance selling online films
and virtual fashion
the luxury industry bounced back
dominated by the mega brands hermes and
chanel and the mega groups lvmh caring
and rishmal
by the first half of 2021 revenues for
some of the biggest names were up as
much as 40 percent on pre-pandemic
levels delivering record profits
from an economic perspective these super
winners are emerging from the pandemic
even stronger
now there is a reawakening in paris the
global capital of luxury fashion
it's a historical echo the last time
fashion bursts back to life here was
after world war ii with the sensation
that was christian dior's new look
it will take more than a new silhouette
to transform the fashion industry now
i mean the big question for me is really
where does the industry go from here and
you know how does it need to adapt and
change to be
kind of fit for this new world that
we're entering
to find out more about this reawakening
i met with a fashion insider with his
finger on the creative pulse of parisian
fashion
pierre
hey ryan hey how are you good how are
you i'm good pierre alexander and pele
also known as pamboy caught the ear of
fashion insiders for his honest online
fashion critiques is that an earring
yeah it's alan crocetti it's like a
little rose
i was like fashion moment
now he collaborates with the respected
fashion editor katie grant at perfect a
fashion media company founded amid the
pandemic
what is lapel like why did you pick this
place who comes here
everyone uh it's you know designers and
you know we we always joke about you
know dress well and come to lapel and
you'll get an internship or you'll find
a job
in the 1960s or 70s there was no luxury
industry yeah you know
but now luxury is this you know global
industry and what's the role of luxury i
mean i think the role of luxury is to
preserve craftsmanship um we tend to you
know look down on manual work and and
craft and i think luxury if anything has
always been about that going back to
louis xiv in france and how he developed
you know the the french the french
fashion industry as we know it today
as you think about the fashion industry
we want to create for the future do you
feel like there's actually
real change happening or is it at the
surface
i mean i feel like changing the
structures of power in the industry and
how they interconnect i feel like
companies need to take risks they need
diversity and inclusion i feel like
fashion is a global conversation
everyone is concerned you know i don't
think that would have happened if it
weren't for the pandemic i mean it was
paris felt weird you know between the
pandemic and the whole conversation of
black lives matter which
was something very new in france i feel
like as soon as we started talking about
systemic racism in the industry a lot of
people reach out to me and came to
realize that passion is also about how
do we want society to be for example in
the 60s with the sexual revolution and
women started wearing miniskirt that was
fashion changing society and shaping
society and and you know pushing new
ideas about womanhood and what a woman
could be and now with men's word there's
been a lot of conversation about
masculinity what it means to be a man
and i think that it's questions that
fashion can answer fashion is probably
the best um you know medium to answer
those questions
i always say it's time to open the
windows we need a fresh breeze of
newness to
kind of you know
swipe through the industry
it really does feel like change is the
watchword here as i caught up with top
designers and creatives
in town for paris fashion week you know
everyone was talking about a reset are
we going back to where we were i hope
not personally but i mean
changes are subtle i mean the truth of
the matter is we we we've got centuries
and i mean decades of this fashion world
and fashion business and hopefully the
mentalities evolve okay and i don't
think we should go back completely to
where we were
there is like it's a big movement going
into that opening of different gender
and also races all that opening the
majority before the opening on the
minority is the ones that are against it
that is the big challenge
[Music]
is
i think that the clientele in the past
two years it's gone from being a very
western clientele actually and one
really rooted in based in the united
states to being much more global
creativity needs to be balanced with
business
the most crucial decision any fashion
ceo makes is the selection of a creative
director who can inform the entire
universe of the brand not just the
collections and the clothes but also the
stores the advertising and in the
digital age the social media strategy
the legendary designer carl lagerfeld
was creative director at fendi for more
than half a century and had a lifelong
contract with chanel where he worked
until he died in 2019
but more recently designers have been
switching sides at a fast clip akin to
soccer managers in transfer season
netting the right striker although in
this game when talents transfer between
historic houses it's known to insiders
as musical chairs
when balenciaga's parent company caring
acquired the brand in 2001 it was doing
only 17.3 million dollars in revenue
that has all changed
analysts say it's doing almost two
billion euros in sales which makes it
one of the biggest most important
fashion houses in the world
a large part of this success is down to
its creative director damn nick vasalia
who has injected his dystopian vision
into the brand with experience honed at
the antwerp academy of fine arts maison
martin margella and louis vuitton
from georgian refugee to master fashion
disruptor demna is part of a group of
designers including virgil abloh and kim
jones who brought the streetwear
phenomenon to the highest levels of
european fashion
he's the creative mind behind
balenciaga's first couture show in more
than 50 years
this is the 50th couture collection
because mr balanciaga himself did 49
collections
so this is the 50th collection it's
demna's first
couture collection
and so it's probably the most important
most anticipated moment of this couture
week
and we're getting the first look at it
it's like the gate to couture that's
correct
so they're about to start the fittings
they have to allocate which model is
going to wear which look
but now the fittings have also become a
moment to capture content to share later
so there's a whole
photograph set up as well
and you can just tell by the energy in
here there's
lots of anticipation because some of the
looks are being revealed for the first
time
nobody in the whole world outside this
building has seen
this collection
and emigre himself cristobal balenciaga
shaped the fashion scene through the
1940s and 50s with his sculptural
masterpieces until he shuttered the
house in 1968.
how are you feeling good ready excited
now it's the moment actually the hardest
one where i cannot change anything
anymore i can just shorten the length so
you're not one of the ones who changes
things the night before no but in
couture also you can't okay our
interview takes place in the recently
restored balenciaga couture salon
where tomorrow in a show with just 128
attendees including kanye west lewis
hamilton and caring chairman and ceo
francois pino
demna will pay homage to the brand's
history underscoring the intimacy and
rarity of oat couture
so i wanted to start with where we are
right now
can you tell me
what this place signifies to the house
of balenciaga
this actual space along where we're
sitting is where
um the couture clients would come during
the cristobal balenciaga era originally
it was the salon it was the salon this
is the place where uh the founder of
this house would come and and and create
his legacy that we're living through
today
it's symbolic i don't know it's symbolic
for my
showing respect to the legacy that i i'm
lucky enough to be in the middle of and
now the couture has been in making for
over one year almost
um and it's the first live event that
we're going to have even if the the
audience is going to be quite restricted
and small what is your vision
for balenciaga couture
my i would say
rather than my vision my mission in
couture
is to actually give it a second life
i heard people saying couture is dead
who needs it you know it's completely
useless and
but i'm afraid of what's going to be in
20 30 years
[Music]
after bursting onto the fashion scene
with the brand collective vet mall
demna took the helm of valenciaga in
2015 as part of a radical modernization
including the triple s which set a fire
the ugly sneaker trend and helped
balenciaga surpass a billion dollars in
revenue in 2019
spawning a thousand copycats
his fashion shows have been as
disruptive as his designs set in an
enormous television studio on the
outskirts of the periphery in paris
he's cast runway models outside the
traditional mold
i like the fact that there's boys at a
couture show that's unusual right
and the balenciaga couture show this
week will feature men
women and non-binary people something
that has not been part of traditional
couture
carl lagerfeld occasionally featured
men's couture on his chanel runways but
it was not made available for sale
i feel like talking about gender is like
talking about the day before yesterday's
news you know we shouldn't even be
talking about it we should just be
living it in fashion and for me
the fact that you saw boys and girls and
non-binary people in my cast
giving couture to men for example for me
they had to pay back someone so i wanted
them to wear heels and to feel how it is
to wear heels and to see what it does
to different type of guys
to some of this motivation to bring this
into kind of mainstream fashion and
culture
come from having grown up in
georgia
during the time of the soviet union
that wasn't a place where
conversations around
gender identity
homosexuality so i think there is a
direct link for me personally with the
culture in which i grew and don't ask
don't tell i mean officially there are
no gays in georgia you know so obviously
it was a taboo subject i mean i've been
more terrorized by homophobia than the
actual civil war so i feel like it is in
me it's something that i i see i have to
it's almost
like a therapy in a way to do that and
since fashion is the mirror of our times
i think it is kind of part of my job
almost yeah
what's your take and what we should
learn from the last
16 months of
pause
um you know i like to raise questions
through my work you know sustainability
like raising questions about consumption
in general i mean it's kind of ironic
because i'm in the middle of the system
that encourages the consumption but what
i'm trying to do bringing couture to it
is actually start a conversation about
thinking twice about consumption i think
you know couture for me
has something very modern in its concept
because we only produce what somebody
orders
so this is like the most sustainable way
of consuming but obviously the industry
cannot live on that but i think it is
also about finding that balance you know
this pandemic made me before pandemic i
never thought about it i was like a
hamster in a wheel just making stuff and
making it and making it but the irony is
you need to sell
mountains of sneakers in order to be
able to sustain both this couture
collection
and the business right you called it
balance i think it is balance i think
it's balanced and it's also
understanding what people want from
fashion i think that's the good starting
point because they don't want all of
that stuff that is being produced they
don't need it they don't want it and to
be honest they don't care about it
fashion has become
too busy to notice that you know the
industry and i feel that pandemic gave
that somehow possibility to take a step
back and to kind of look at it from
objectively and just to understand you
don't need all of that
[Music]
recognizing the impact fashion has on
the planet is a step forward
but the scale of the problem is vast and
the necessary change can feel
intimidating
some designers prefer to work outside of
the big houses turning down lucrative
offers instead to focus on their own
brands
one such designer is the rising star of
paris fashion whose studio in the 19th
arondi small is bursting with old
garments that she repurposes to create
her highly acclaimed collections
i met with marine ser to get her take on
how the pandemic is changing fashion and
to learn if that change is happening
fast enough
so this is our upcycled room where we
are making garments from regenerative
fabric we take this from warehouses it's
all waste and i already used garments
like do they just sell it in bulk yeah
so they have like tones and tones and
tones of garment when you enter into
this place you realize also
how fashion industry i've been like
producing so much the last 50 years yeah
so basically this is our past i mean
this is the past of fashion and we are
like taking piece of it um and selecting
into that to make new garments and then
no garment is the same either right
because every piece is yeah every piece
is different all of them they are unique
and the only thing that repeats is the
process of making but indeed the piece
itself like if this will be
on the back of your shirt all of the
shirt would be different right
it was marine's grandfather a collector
and second-hand dealer who first taught
her the value of vintage
looking at fashion through an ethical
and sustainable lens allowed marine to
foresee many of the issues that the
industry is only just starting to wake
up to
you know you clearly feel very deeply
about the state of the world you think
deeply about
the climate and the environment
but you're now saying you feel
optimistic
well i think before it was more about
ringing the bell alarming people
but because like in the fashion industry
no one was looking at that
and i was also working for this industry
so i do not want it to be a part of
just being there making one more skirt
you know i was hoping that maybe you
know some other people of the fashion
industry were thinking about that too we
really have to think about
yeah the environment that we are living
in and the planet that we are destroying
every day so if i'm there i have to at
least um
making a small change so what is luxury
to you and what is that luxury customer
that you are
appealing to what are they looking for i
believe that you can feel it when you
touch it i think people that are in
fashion for long they will know you know
how this thing is stitch and even if you
don't know like this old thing you will
feel it if like for me it's really
joyful when i take a cushion cover and i
can transform it into a
shirt that look cool i'm like yeah
that's nice
what is the goal of the company
i think the goal of the of the company
is to um
question
the fashion industry try to resolve some
of the questions i mean basically every
day we are doing that
and
it's to make an ecosystem
a new ecosystem um kind of exists
a fashion business does not succeed on
aesthetics alone
now more than ever those designs need to
be rooted in clear values
sustainability for me it has become a
very personal thing really just maybe
doing couture is my way taking
a minute of silence almost to reflect
this is why the show will be in full
silence
no music there will be no music the
first time i never showed my work in
silence wow
that minute of silence
is very symbolic from what i just told
you about fashion as an industry all the
white noise things that don't matter
i've seen designers injecting more of
their personal values into their designs
and asking provocative questions about
fashion and its role in the world
marine and demnar are asking how fashion
can more positively impact the people in
our communities the societies we live in
and the planet we all share
[Music]
[Music]
you